Hey, Kelly, it's Sue.
I'm the voice in the hands
behind the Knit It Now videos.
You took time to write to me today about
a cast-on method that you're
using and you're unhappy with.
Let me read to you exactly what you said.
"Every time I start to knit and put
the comb on, the comb pulls stitches down,
so there are big holes,
and the comb falls off the stitches."
It took me a minute to figure out what it
is that was happening,
and when you told me that you were using
an LK-150 machine, the light bulb came on.
Looking at the LK 150 manual,
this is the cast on that they tell you.
They teach you how to use.
And that's what it looks like.
It's not you.
You didn't do anything wrong.
You don't have the wrong cast on comb.
It's just ugly.
This is probably what
you're seeing right?Now
there's nothing wrong with this cast-on.
It's a closed cast-on.
The stitches are not going to run,
and it has lots and lots of uses.
And again, the key to this cast-on is fast.
So if you're going to scrap on,
you're knitting a swatch, you don't
need to have a nice pretty finish.
This one's perfect,
and we use it all the time.
But since you don't like the appearance of
it, you need to learn a different cast-on.
Now, the one I would recommend you
to start with is an e-wrap cast on.
E-wrap cast-on is very easy to do.
It's stretchy, and it has a nice finish.
So I recommend that you take a look in our
Learning Library and search
for cast on methods.
There's a number of them there.
Part of your learning journey is to master
a number of techniques and figure out
when it is that you would use them.
Now, the next step on your journey from
casting on would be to putting a hem.
Now, I'm reading into your message
that you didn't like this ugly finish
because you wanted to start
a scarf or a blanket.
And you've got this ugly all
these loops hanging right?
The next thing you're going to need
to learn is hems. In machine knitting
we want to finish that edge.
So you've got a pretty beginning to your
scarf or your blanket or your sweater
or whatever it is you're knitting.
So the next thing to look
for in the learning library are hems.
We also have a Home Study Course
for absolute beginners that covers
both hems and casting on.
And I believe that information in there
would be very valuable to you as well.
So, again, thanks for writing.
Try some different techniques.
You aren't doing anything wrong.
and happy knitting.